loxstedt
das zu wenig
[Musik]
laut spät
georgen
mister alten
sagen
wenn wir jetzt sagen ich merke wenn ich
genug nach und der brand auf seinen
schultern
welche
[Musik]
kritiker der nothilfen zur im sommer und
die anderen sind selbst und ziemlich
unnötig aber nicht stattfinden
der 8 in der lage schwierig
statt
einige bewegte
verstorben vor und die zweite zone
[Musik]
der gestorben
gerade große
kleinstädte aus
[Musik]
und beatrice beide filter die fixe
berufssoldaten an der drogen formt sie
stellen den tisch zur verfügung
eine kiste eine schachtel ein bügelbrett
die löffel zum auflösen der drogen die
spritzen eisen in die szenen sprache das
wasser die alkohol tupfer ihr lohn die
zigarettenfilter durch die der fixe den
stoff in die spitze gezogen hat fünf bis
zehn filter geben eine spritze einen
knall
[Musik]
bitterli fixer sind profis kleingewerbe
ihren stoff ehrlich und hart verdienen
einzelkämpfer und schwerstabhängige
viele kunden bedeuten viele filter und
denn rundherum geknallt wird dann knall
noch sie konsum animiert jeder raucher
weißes 10 20 30 schnelle im tag das was
fast alle auf der gasse konsumieren
cocktails heroin und kokain gemischt
gewählt ist
[Musik]
pölten
jeder hat hier in fernen auftaucht hat
der alte frau untersuchen und zu hause
da ein
die kurzgeschichten
hypnotisch
und im four seasons resort usb sticks le
mans zu
es gibt leute die sagen sich ich bin ich
bilde mir das wirklich noch nur sehr
genau
ganz gut
er wird das theaterstück mixtape
das hinein
vor zuzug
keinesfalls
jetzt drehen sowie die city
die politik zu
das ist das spiel morgen für und zum
norden oder bis die knie küsste vor sich
haben oder dann ich denke mir ab nachdem
nico in hägelberg und dann hat man
gesagt das sandbox als notfall ins
spital
ein spitalarzt mit dem foto operiert und
der sportdirektor
das ist das wo andere tor anzeigte grund
sie ihre muskeln
sie wollen zu hause das rund davon
derart plump
das arabische wort hat sich eingebürgert
jeder fixer kennt den warnruf der die
polizei ankündigt
berlin
das ewig gleiche spiel drei bis vier mal
jeden tag manchmal kommen acht manchmal
100 alles rennt weg dealer versuchen den
stoff zu verstecken
dann ist es vorbei die szene
reorganisiert sich
ursula
und los bauen der mit gestellt
ich hatte sie im sommer kennengelernt
pfarrer sieber als drogenklinik von dort
ging sie in den zug und die therapie und
heute wieder
bad muskau
[Musik]
ja
ihm ist es der harmonie kosten
aber nicht bemüht da weiß gott
news com idyllischen rahmen und so in
der unterwelt
ich bin immer noch 108 ich bin
wir werden unser planet völlig das ist
total sound des landes in andere
sprachen russischen freund spruch was
mir redet
mit riecht ist nur ein beispiel
besuchen sie http t.co freundin personen
an kommt auch mit ihrer kazior lang sind
immer zu amüsieren forscht sind fast auf
einen sie wollen und dezember - und noch
immer noch ohne zurück nimmt sie sich
klammern oder
mit
was
das spiel
sandvik nichts verdient wird wird nicht
verdient
10 august
gb
die unesco verliehen
dieser effekt
ich hoffe handy
später bin ich
ich besuche sie bekommt immer aktiver
nutzer an die schule
das abgeben müssen
trotzdem muss probiert mit kollegen und
ziegen sachen immigranten wenn ihr 12
sie kümmert sich auch um mich mich
trifft ebenso gut eine spiel und sind so
auch wieder
und sie schafft das
london
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
mehr
ja
so
hier
so lange schon
[Musik]
maro tosetti rossi genannt gelernte
elektromechaniker fixer seit 14 jahren
jetzt vollberuflich bezieht eine kleine
iv rente wegen eines schweren unfalls
schläft tagsüber in einer öffentlichen
toilette am letten schlafen liegt nicht
drin weil alles geklaut wird
die mx
sein ski
mehr
das ist traurig fast
noch immer
[Musik]
wir sehen
eintracht passiert
[Musik]
das thema aufgriff
schon wieder
wenig
das immer wieder engagiert und drei uhr
nachts zusammenräumen politische unter
den arm klemmen abhauen immer wieder
hätten immer wieder letzten tag und
nacht in den og anzug das über
gewöhnlich steigen die leute vor sich
her treiben zusehen wie sie sich 100
meter weiter wieder einrichten das ewig
gleiche spiel
wird er spielen
rossi
[Musik]
die stellen würden
der schmutz
ok
doch
[Musik]
so lee
zum stehen gekommen
doch stets rom mit
das
geschlagen
[Musik]
entkräftet
ausschnitt schnell
[Musik]
sie kommt
abreißen
sie rufen
marburg
der welt
[Applaus]
nichts können
stehen
zum 20
sauber muss es sein ordentlich
aufgeräumt
man muss freundlich sein zu den kunden
auch wenn sie eklig sind auch wenn man
krank ist immer höflich der berufsstolz
der filter lief xr in beatrice
das ja
stick
eigentlich gibt nichts mehr in den fuß
von wert ist geschwollen die venen kaum
mehr zu erkennen
paul probiert es trotzdem sein
liebesdienst 20 minuten suche nach einer
vene
[Musik]
ruhig
dicht
das ganze
und die songs stark
schulz wir uns entlang
gibt
schoko
müssen
simon
es ist kein schwein hoch
ja
[Musik]
viel spaß
totschlag stehen
[Musik]
genau
für
[Musik]
beatrice und paul haben seit monaten
keine wohnung mehr
die zuständige notschlafstelle wetzikon
ist im moment für sie verschlossen
man soll höchstens einen monat dort
bleiben können und in dieser zeit seine
situation klären
gedacht ist das als anreiz zum
aussteigen
die praxis nach einem warte monat dürfen
sie zurück wer drews und paul warten und
suche nach einer anderen
schlafgelegenheit heute haben sie glück
in wädenswil 30 minuten von zürich
carol ist erschöpft und fieber
ich muss
am andern tag suchen wir vergeblich und
finden ihn schließlich in der
notfallstation des spitals
unter passiert muss
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mexiko
[Musik]
und noch jemand den film im spital
ursula mit ihren eltern selbst vor ein
paar tagen nachts um 3 uhr mit einem
dealer für dem sie geschöpft das heißt
vermittelt hat kraft bekommen um ihren
lohn
er war wie ein fläschchen hin und sagte
es sei methadon
sie trank ist schwer verladen schon mit
heroin kokain methadon
es war ammoniak das auf der gasse
gebraucht wird um aus kokain freebase er
zu stehen
ja ich bin verbraucht ich vorne weg und
deswegen einfach no go diesem morgen
vorgesehen ist
wenn so eine kraus zu besuchen und dort
so viel später und gehen
[Musik]
ganz offiziell
ja
[Musik]
das konnte schon früh in kassel
staudämmen und die schwierigste versetzt
zu haben ohne die startelf der profi du
breit grauen der bahn
und das passiert mir gut
den fahrgästen fließen
du bist jetzt wieder zu wenig
sehr bekannt
einmal fixiert
nicht bewegt ebenso trägt
zugleich jungs so richtig doch gebaut
noch nicht fix
die lappen
[Musik]
jeder hat sie gesucht
wie grüßen
[Musik]
als konsum
durch geschäftliche
wie sehen sie das
eine hälfte gehört soziales
das hat sich gerächt
nicht gebunden also jetzt
so
[Musik]
die wirtschaft geht kein problem
groß
rossi mit filter tisch unterwegs zu
einem der eckpunkte seiner kleinen welt
ok
[Applaus]
hey baby doc
toby page
hallo
[Musik]
sieht man
[Applaus]
solche zu verstehen wo ist das klingt es
aus wenn er ganz normal
[Gelächter]
worauf sie duschen
[Musik]
so haben sie umweltministerium
das geht nicht
der 17
[Musik]
577 de ski
da
[Musik]
das gefühl
wir sind bald passieren
[Musik]
wie stark sie an zu benzin wenn sie sich
beim transport
[Musik]
[Applaus]
s
wetten ein medien futter
durchschnittlich 20 fernseher geben pro
woche aus aller welt diesmal das welche
fernsehen als zeuge einer brachts aktion
veteran post ist voller bewunderung
der neue mini kommt
dass man ein gerät sich super geschlagen
das ist genial wachstum ist da nicht
[Musik]
wie so oft die lösung für lokführer ist
wird so der vorstand
sternkopf
[Musik]
diese fläche
diese läuft
das
die
und wieder einmal anders
feierabend für beatrice und paul der
warte monate ist vorbei sie können
wieder einen monat lang nach mexiko die
nächste drehung in einem mühsamen fix
erleben
ich merke dass ich fix und strickobjekte
berufspädagogik mit dem haus rückte und
so dass ich gar nicht so extrem ich das
mal zu sein und macht unternehmen auf
215 euro danach scheint dann fühlst du
gut bist kurz war mit dem boden rein und
den klatsch als noch am unteren viel und
sehr gut trainiert habe er den schnitt
mit verletzten und der fertigung das
luftig aussage text
wir spielten stücke geschrieben und
diese produkte kosten
danke ich den gleichen ich sehe mich
dass sie von morgen
irgendwie weiß sie nicht wo waren das
sind schon sehr schwierig wenn das
tragen musste wie es ganz gut war ganz
schön erwachsen
das verstoße das ist dieselbe
wenn es ganz schön wäre so wie es mit
ihren selbst der wind werden jährlich
zahlen
die vorstellung ist einfach schwierig
verlässliche gebaut oder selber muss
frau auch hinter auch sowas schon direkt
ich muss ehrlich sie sonst bis zum jetzt
die gemeinde thema aktuelle einfach
einmal entgegen dem trend und zu sagen
so ich fühle mich jetzt so werner ley
mit der aus wir unsere motorschäden
fortan ist erkannt und wollte ich vor
fünf jahren praktisch nicht groß gemacht
weshalb man komme mit dem abgrund
das ist sicher so 90s niederselters
grund jetzt fix foxi wodurch august was
ich weiß dass ich mache natürlich gibt
es über da haben wir doch so besorgt bis
die scharte grund dass sie irgendwie
immer gern mal single pussy schon
irgendwo der ewige liebe und
geborgenheit
das würde den gern münchen geholt was er
wann das land gefordert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
notschlafstelle wetzikon das zuhause für
einen weiteren monat
von abends neuen bis morgens 9
zum symbolischen preis von 5 franken pro
nacht bezahlen dass der monatlichen
fürsorge gelb
[Musik]
das hat die regierung nicht auf
dort hat es durch wieder zu
so
[Musik]
bunker helvetiaplatz beratungsstelle und
notschlafstelle ein wenig ruhe eisen
1000he trinken duschen
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
knallen wenn keiner hinsieht
jetzt machen auch nichts raus dann
müsste ich werde geschwächt
das bin ich jetzt das geht den umschlag
[Musik]
diese
zu lösen sind
geworden war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ann duffy serie
[Musik]
das ist das duschen und klassischen
zwischendurch
dann auch wieder ändern
ums leben
[Musik]
vielleicht war sie zwar wird sich
wiederholen
da werden wir noch mal eingehen die
chance
die auf ihre räder profil war aber der
grund sie sind sehr viel haben der bund
und die glaube lawrow des hörens
doch nicht immer ist es gibt neben einem
8er witz so leute etwa abgelegt
so dass gott zu crysis angebracht wie
sehr sie sehen sind die drucker sie
wissen drogen station und die wiesn ist
beschäftigt leim und dieser sich
erstaunt die bibel so aus dass nach dem
bezahlen dass man darüber redet viel
mehr wiederbeleben tod der schon angst
und so wichtig
[Musik]